RADIO SYNDICATED SHOW 575
STATIONS.
WE HAVE MORE AND THIS ON OUR
BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
>> BRAND NEW SCANDAL
INVOLVING ANTI-TRUMP FBI
LOVE BIRDS, PETER STRZOK AND
LISA PAGE NEWLY OBTAINED
TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN STRZOK
AND PAGE REVEALING DAMNING
NEW INFORMATION.
STRZOK WE FIND OUT TODAY IS
FRIENDS WITH FEDERAL JUDGE
RUDOLPH CAN
RUDOLPH CONTERAS WHO SITS ON
THE FISA COURT.
ATTENDING COCKTAIL PARTY
WITH THIS JUDGE.
NOW HERE IS WHAT IS
DISTURBING.
THE JUDGE PRESIDED OVER THE
HEARING WHERE LIEUTENANT
GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN PLED
GUILTY TO LYING TO THE FBI.
THERE IS A LOT OF OTHER
IMPORTANT CONTEXT TO EXPLAIN
HERE.
WE WILL DO THAT IN JUST A
MINUTE.
FIRST, TAKE A LOOK AT BRAND
NEW TEXT MESSAGES.
START JULY 25TH, 2016.
PAGE WRITES.
RUDY, THE JUDGE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
IS ON THE FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SURVEILLANCE
COURT.
DID YOU KNOW THAT?
AND PAGE ADDS JUST, YOU
KNOW, APPOINTED TWO MONTHS
AGO.
STRZOK.
I DID.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT IT
BEFORE AND AFTER I NEED TO
GET TOGETHER WITH HIM SO
STRZOK AND JUDGE CONTRERAS
KNOW EACH OTHER.
PAGE LETTER WRITES READ
THROUGH THIS, THOUGHT OF IT
BECAUSE YOU HAD TO GOOGLE
FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
SURVEILLANCE COURT JUDGES
AND SAW HIM THERE.
I'M TELLING YOU.
STRZOK FOLLOWS UP WITH WELL
SHE BROUGHT UP A GOOD POINT
ABOUT BEING CIRCUMSPECT IN
TALKING TO HIM IN TERMS OF
NOT PLACING HIM IN A
SITUATION WHERE HE'D HAVE TO
ACTUALLY RECUSE HIMSELF.
PAGE THEN TEXTS I CAN'T
IMAGINE EITHER ONE OF YOU
EVER TALKING ABOUT ANYTHING
IN DETAIL, MEANINGFUL ENOUGH
TO WARRANT A RECUSAL.
AND PAGE SAYS WELL, ANYWAY,
MAYBE YOU DIDN'T MEAN TO BUT
DIDN'T.
AND STRZOK ANSWERS REALLY?
RUDY?
I'M IN CHARGE OF ESPIONAGE
FOR THE FBI.
ANY ESPIONAGE FISA COMES
BEFORE HIM, WHAT SHOULD HE
DO?
GIVEN HIS FRIEND OVERSEES
THEM?
PAGE REPLIES IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE STANDARDS
FOR RECUSAL THOUGH ARE QUITE
HIGH.
I JUST DON'T THINK THIS
POSES AN ACTUAL CONFLICT.
AND HE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT YOU
DO.
AND THEN STRZOK RESPONDS
YEAH, GENERALLY DOES KNOW
WHAT I DO, NOT TO THE LEVEL
OF THE SCOPE OR AREA, BUT HE
IS SUPER THOUGHTFUL AND
RIGOROUS ABOUT ETHICS AND
CONFLICTS.
AND SUGGESTING A SOCIAL
SETTING WITH OTHERS WOULD
PROBABLY BE BETTER THAN A
ONE-ON-ONE MEETING.
I'M SORRY, I'M JUST GOING TO
HAVE TO INVITE YOU TO THE
COCKTAIL PARTY.
YOU CAN SIT NEXT TO ME.
I'M ADDING THAT PART.
STRZOK CONTINUES, OF COURSE,
YOU'LL BE THERE.
HAVE TO COME UP WITH SOME
OTHER WORK PEOPLE COVER FOR
ACTION.
AND PAGE WRITES WHY MORE?
SIX IS PERFECTLY FINE FOR A
DINNER PARTY.
OH, SIX, INTIMATE SETTING,
THEY KNOW EACH OTHER, HE IS
IN HIS POSITION, THE JUDGE
IN HIS POSITION.
THERE IS A LOT TO UNPACK
HERE.
WHAT IS CLEAR IS THAT PETER
STRZOK KNEW THE JUDGE AND
THAT BOTH HE AND PAGE WANTED
TO ATTEND A PARTY WITH HIM
THAT IS A MASSIVE CONFLICT
OF INTEREST.
ENGINEERING A MEETING WITH
FISA JUDGE UNDER FALSE
PRETENSES IN THIS CASE A
COCKTAIL PARTY THAT COULD
ACTUALLY BE ON DESTRUCTION
AND OTHER CRIMINAL
LIABILITY.
WE WILL ASK GREGG JARRETT IN
A MINUTE.
WHAT IS REALLY INEXCUSABLE
IS THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOUGHT LIKE HELL,
ESPECIALLY ROD ROSENSTEIN TO
KEEP THIS INFORMATION
SECRET.
NOW, SARA CARTER REPORTING
THAT CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATORS WORKING FOR
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN,
CONGRESSMAN MARK MEADOWS,
THEY DISCOVERED THESE TEXT
MESSAGES AT THE DOJ'S
HEADQUARTERS AND THIS IS
PART OF THE OUTRAGE.
ACCORDING TO SARA CARTER OF
THE 1.2 MILLION DOCUMENTS
THE DOJ INSPECTOR GENERAL
HAS AQUIRTD, THE HOUSE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE HAS ONLY
RECEIVED JUST OVER 3,000,
QUOTE, UNIQUE DOCUMENTS.
THAT MEANS THE DOJ NEVER
EVER WANTED THE STUNNING
INFORMATION TO GET OUT.
THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
HIDE IT.
REMEMBER BACK IN JANUARY,
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROD ROSENSTEIN BEGGING IN
THE FINAL HOURS BEFORE THEY
HAD TO TURN THIS INFORMATION
OVER, BEGGING SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE PAUL RYAN, ALLOW THE
DOJ NOT TO TURN OVER THE
DOCUMENTS RELATED TO THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION TO
DEVIN NUNES AND THESE
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES.
IT'S NOW CLEAR WHY ROD
ROSENSTEIN, YEAH THAT GUY
THAT APPOINTED MUELLER NOW
DID THIS.
IT'S ALL PART OF A YEAR LONG
PATTERN OF OBSTRUCTION.
OF STONEWALLING.
NONCOMPLIANCE, AND CONGRESS'
ENFORCE, BY THE WAY AND
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY TO
INVESTIGATE AND OVERSEE THE
ACTIONS AT THE DOJ.
YOU KNOW, IT'S CALLED CHECKS
AND BALANCES.
THINK ABOUT THIS FOR A
SECOND.
IF ROD ROSENSTEIN HAD HIS
WAY, WE WOULDN'T KNOW ABOUT
ANY OF THESE SCANDALS.
PEOPLE NOW NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS IS WHY PEOPLE LIKE, OH,
GRASSLEY AND TILLIS AND
CORNYN AND GRAHAM ARE
DEMANDING AS WE HAVE BEEN
DEMANDING FOR A YEAR A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
INVESTIGATE THE
INVESTIGATORS.
THEY CAN'T INVESTIGATE
THEMSELVES.
AS FOR THAT VERY IMPORTANT
CONTEXT, WE LEARNED THAT
STRZOK AND JUDGE CONTRERAS
WERE FRIENDS AND THAT JUDGE
CONTRERAS OVERSAW THE FLYNN
CASE WHICH AFTER HE ACCEPTED
THE CASE WAS A MYSTERY.
WHY DID HE RECUSE HIMSELF?
NOW, WE STILL DON'T KNOW THE
EXACT REASON WHY, BUT THIS
COULD HAVE SOMETHING TO DO
WITH IT.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT PETER
STRZOK WAS THE FBI AGENT.
HE OVERSAW THE JANUARY 2017
WHITE HOUSE INTERVIEW OF
LIEUTENANT GENERAL FLYNN AND
HERE'S WHAT WE REALLY NEED
MORE INFORMATION ON, STRZOK
IS THE FORMER FBI COUNTER
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIAL WHO
SIGNED THE PAPERWORK TO
START THE ENTIRE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
AND AS THESE NEW TEXT
MESSAGES REVEALED, JUDGE
CONTRERAS WAS ON THE FISA
COURT.
AND SOURCES HAVE BEEN
TELLING US THAT JUDGE
CONTRERAS MAY HAVE SIGNED
OFF ON ONE OF THE FISA
APPLICATIONS TO APPROVE THE
WARRANT TO SPY ON CARTER
PAGE, TRUMP ASSOCIATE WHICH
MEANS THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
WHICH LIKELY GAVE THE FBI
ACCESS TO TRUMP CAMPAIGN
COMMUNICATIONS.
THIS IS STUNNING.
IT IS CORRUPT.
IT IS AN ABUSE OF POWER.
AND IT SHOWS INEXCUSABLE
BIASES AND CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE HAS TRIED TO
CONCEAL.
NOW, WE NEED TO KNOW ALL THE
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN
STRZOK, PAGE, AND CONTRERAS,
AS A MATTER OF FACT, WE
LEASE ALL THE STRZOK/PAGE
TEXT MESSAGES, EVERYTHING
YOU HAVE GOT.
WE NEED TO FIND OUT IF
STRZOK WAS INVOLVED IN
PUTTING TOGETHER THE FISA
APPLICATION FOR CARTER PAGE.
HE WAS A FORMER HIGH RANKING
COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIAL WHO WAS BRAGGING
ABOUT IT.
THE FISA WARRANT FOR PAGE
WAS SIGNED IN OCTOBER 2016.
STRZOK WAS FIRED FROM
MUELLER'S TEAM IN AUGUST OF
2017.
SO, IT IS TIME FOR STRZOK TO
TELL US WHAT DID HE KNOW?
WHEN DID HE KNOW IT?
HOW DOES THIS GUY HAVE A
JOB?
LISA PAGE WAS ADVISING
ANDREW MCCABE.
WE DID REACH OUT TO JUDGE
CONTRERAS FOR COMMENT.
HE DIDN'T GET BACK TO US.
ALSO BREAKING RIGHT NOW,
"U.S.A. TODAY" IS REPORTING
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
CONSIDERING PUBLICLY
RELEASING PARTS OF THE FISA
SURVEILLANCE ORDER AGAINST
CARTER PAGE.
HOW ABOUT RELEASING ALL OF
IT.
NOW, THIS WOULD MEAN WE
WOULD GET TO SEE EXACTLY HOW
THAT FAKE NEWS DOSSIER, THE
BULK OF WHICH WAS USED TO
GET THE FISA WARRANT AGAINST
PAGE WAS USED AND HOW THE
FBI MISLEAD ON PURPOSE,
PURPOSE LIVE OMITTED
INFORMATION TO FISA JUDGES
ABOUT CLINT THAT SHE BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR FAKE NEWS PHONY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
AND ALSO TONIGHT, A
SIGNIFICANT NEW DEVELOPMENT
SPEAKING OF CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, FOX NEWS TONIGHT
REPORTING A BRITISH COURT IS
NOW ORDERING STEELE TO SIT
FOR A VIDEOTAPED DEPOSITION
AS PART OF AN ONGOING LEGAL
BATTLE AGAINST BUZZFEED, THE
WEBSITE THAT PUBLISHED THE
FAKE NEWS DOSSIER.
NOW, TO CALL THIS HUGE IS A
MASSIVE UNDERSTATEMENT.
NOW, STEELE WILL LIKELY BE
FORCED TO TRY AND VERIFY THE
DOSSIER THAT HE AND FUSION
GPS AND THE FBI NEVER
VERIFIED, NEVER
CORROBORATED.
SO, IN OTHER WORDS, STEELE
WILL UNDER OATH HAVE TO
ADMIT WHETHER OR NOT HE KNEW
THE DOSSIER WAS FULL OF LIES
FROM HIS PHONY RUSSIAN
SOURCES.
BUT GAVE IT TO THE FBI
ANYWAY.
AND ACCORDING TO THAT YOU
BOOK, STEELE TOLD FRIENDS
THAT IT WAS KIND OF 50/50
ABOUT THE MOST SALACIOUS
PART OF THE DOSSIER.
THAT'S THE PART THAT
INVOLVED THE HOOKERS AT THE
RITZ CARLTON URINATING ON A
BED.
AND WE ALSO HAVE LEARNED
MORE ABOUT STEELE'S USE OF
CURRENT AND FORMER RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT SOURCES.
WE'RE GOING TO BE FOLLOWING
THIS STORY VERY CLOSELY.
BUT ALSO BREAKING RIGHT NOW,
NEW DETAILS ON THE TIME LINE
FOR FORMER DEPUTY FBI
DIRECTOR ANDREW MCCABE TO BE
FIRED AND LOSE HIS PENSION.
NOW WE'RE LEARNING THAT THE
DEADLINE COULD NOW BE
SATURDAY.
AND AS WE HAVE BEEN
EXPLAINING THE FACT THAT
MCCABE IS EVEN IN THIS
POSITION IS STUNNING.
IT IS INEXCLUSIVE.
IS ININEXCUSABLE.
IT MEANS HE DID SOMETHING
DRASTICALLY RADICALLY WRONG.
OUR SOURCES ARE TELLING US
MCCABE COULD END UP FACING
MULTIPLE CRIMINAL CHARGES.
FORGET ABOUT THE PENSION.
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO,
MCCABE WAS PUT ON LEAVE
AFTER CURRENT FBI DIRECTOR
CHRISTOPHER WRAY WAS
REPORTEDLY INFORMED THAT
MCCABE WAS GOING TO BE
EXPOSED IN THE UPCOMING
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR THAT
REPORT.
THEN ALSO TONIGHT AS WE HAVE
PREDICTED FOR MONTHS, THE
DISGRACED FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR JIM COMEY, OH, IS
HE PREPARED TO CASH IN ON
HIS NEW FOUND FAME.
DID I PREDICT THAT YOU KNOW,
IN JUST A FEW WEEKS, COMEY
IS GOING TO KICK OFF HIS
WHIRLWIND BOOK TOUR.
HE HAS TOUGH INTERVIEWS WITH
STEPHEN COLBERT, CLINTON
SYCOPHANT GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS AND LADIES OF
"THE VIEW."
ACCORDING TO THAT YOU REPORT
FROM AXIOS, COMEY IS
PLANNING TO COME OUT HOT AND
CORRECT ALL THE SO-CALLED
LIES ABOUT HIM AND THE FBI.
FOR MONTHS WE HAVE LITERALLY
BEEN BRINGING YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ON A NIGHTLY
BASIS BREAKING NEWS,
HARD-HITTING, INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTS ABOUT THE CORRUPTION
AT SOME OF THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF OUR GOVERNMENT
INCLUDING THE SHOCKING
DETAILS ABOUT THE ABUSE OF
POWER AT THE VERY TOP OF THE
PHISH.
FBI.
JAMES COMEY YOU WANT TO COME